en janvier 1989 ça sent le roussi chez
les girondins bordeaux à la une de ce
journal la crise financière des
girondins de bordeaux une crise
financière qui va durer des mois à
l'époque bordeaux vient de connaître son
âge d'or et de remporter des titres à la
pelle mais en 1990 les victoires c'est
terminé et pourtant le club a gardé le
même train de vie qu'avant la cause de
cette dégradation économique un train de
vie fastueux la flambée des salaires des
recettes publicitaires insuffisantes et
la dncg le gendarme financier du
football veille dans son viseur le
sulfureux président de gironde 1 claude
bez les ennuis continuent pour claude
bez le pouvoir absolu du président des
girondins vacille très très fort le
patron des girondins est accusé d'avoir
détourné 45 millions de francs des
caisses du club le 12 septembre 1990
le feuilleton médiatique continue et
claude bez s'emporte violemment contre
les journalistes semblaient des films
part et vous
malgré le scandale un homme apporte un
soutien sans faille à claude bez c'est
jacques chaban delmas maire de bordeaux
et ancien premier ministre qui veut y
avait sept ans coca mais pour leproux et
d'autres aussi et que personne ne soit
épargné
que tous les coquins soient démasqués
jugés condamnés et vidé
c'est ma poésie dans 2 novembre 1990
claude bez est inculpé d'escroquerie
d'abus de confiance et de complicité de
faux
il laisse derrière lui une dette de 300
millions de francs au club pour bordeaux
le dépôt de bilan n'est plus très loin
les hirondelles france était tout pour
parce que moi je suis gérant d une
inquiétude confirmé le 15 mai 1991 c'est
la fin du feuilleton médiatique et
l'heure de la liquidation judiciaire
pour bordeaux conséquence le club est
rétrogradé en deuxième division par le
conseil d'état je pensais sincèrement qu
on allait rester en première division
[Musique]
je pouvais mal imaginé après ce que j'ai
connu ici que on devrait redescendre
comme ça en division 2 trente ans plus
tard en 2022 l'ombre d'une nouvelle
relégation administrative plane sur les
girondins pour rester en ligue 2 le club
doit trouver 22 millions d'euros dans le
pire des cas à bordeaux pourrait être
rétrogradée en 5e division par la dncg
signant la disparition du club
[Musique]